[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout
if you're joining for the first time
it's great to meet you i'm rachel i'm
the host of the data science hangout
if this is your first hangout this is an
open space for the whole data science
community to connect and chat about data
science leadership
questions you're facing and
really what's going on in the world of
data science
i'll also say as i mentioned last time
if you are watching this on youtube in
the future
you can also join us live and we'd love
to have you
but we always want to create spaces
where everybody can participate and we
can hear from everyone
i'm getting a little bit of
background but um
there's three ways to ask questions so
you could jump in live you can raise
your hand on zoom you can put questions
in the zoom chat
and just put a little star next to your
question
in the zoom chat if you want me to read
it out loud
but we also have a slido link where you
can ask questions anonymously too and
someone from our studio will help share
that in the chat in just a moment
but i just want to reiterate we love to
hear from everyone no matter your level
of experience or area of work
so today i'm so excited to be joined by
my co-host jenny listman jenny is a
director of research at state space
and jenny i'd love to have you introduce
yourself i know you've been on here a
few weeks before
but share a bit about your work hi um
well so first thanks so much for having
me
um and thanks to our studio in general
for providing this um
this forum for the for the community
it's great
um so
i'm director of research at statespace
labs and i think
probably most people don't know of the
company um some people may know of some
of our products but without knowing the
the name of the company um so it was
founded by neuroscientists who
met at nyu it was founded about five
years ago
um so the company combines
neuroscience
gaming and ai to um
build products that help people
maximize their performance and connect
with other people while having fun um so
that's that's vague but the underlying
technology is based on research methods
from sensory motor neuroscience and
and cognitive uh psychology
um
so the
there are multiple products that the
company has if you're a gamer in
particular if you're an fps gamer you
might know of our first product which is
called
aimlab which is um
a first person shooter uh assessment and
training scenario although
a lot of people use it just because they
think it's fun so they play it as a game
on its own
we also have aim blocks which is
aim lab in roblox
we also have two
uh esports and and gaming coaching
platforms um
where we can connect players with with
coaches and training content
and we also have a digital health group
that's been working for a while in
stealth mode so i think most people have
no idea
especially people who are familiar with
the company through
aimlab or aimblox they have no idea that
we have a digital health
arm so the digital health group is
working on gamified
cognitive and motor performance
assessments
um
and
the
so the company
you know while it's
founded it was founded by scientists
and the underlying methods uh
and
the underlying analytical methods and
assessment methods or strategies are
developed in-house by scientists
many of the other people who work at the
company come from
the gaming industry or are die-hard
gamers so
the engineers the designers user
experience marketing
um and analytics there are people who
either came from gaming the gaming
industry or
are really serious gamers
um we also have former esports pros and
and coaches streamers uh working at the
company
um
so that's
that's
state space i don't know if i think i
saw one person nodding when i said aim
lab so you know maybe we have some
some players here
um
yeah
yeah and to maybe put us all in kind of
like
your frame of reference too i'm curious
what are some of the business problems
or things that you're helping to solve
or things your team's working on too
um
so
the
the company
has i i would divide our
data
questions problems goals into kind of
two
two buckets so first of all i should
preface that by saying
a lot of people assume that because
aimlab is free
uh i think the default you know
assumption is that we're selling
people's data which we're not
uh
we just keep all of the data in-house
and and do the you know use it to
improve the product or build other
products
um
so that's number one um but i would say
we have two different
buckets of data and analysis needs so
one
is
the kind that
you might
encounter at a company another company
with a customer facing products so
retention customer segmentation
marketing analytics a b testing so we
have those needs
but there's also
a lot of
science going on at the company so we
have another bucket of data needs that
might be
more what you would expect at a digital
health company
um or even in an academic lab so even
that even applies to
the aimlab product or or roblox product
so even the gaming products and not just
the digital health products
um
we're still
doing things like
um you know figuring out how do we
measure certain aspects of of human
cognitive or motor performance
through their interactions with a
computer
um how do we extract scientifically
valid signals from the data
how do we estimate
um the extent to which different
environmental factors or practice habits
affect performance
um so
so i
yeah when i think about our data needs i
sort of bucket them into these these two
categories
so we have yeah we have it so we have a
data an analytics group that works
on
the
um
the problems that you you might normally
associate with a data science or or
analytics group and then we have an r d
group or a science team that works on a
lot of the other
the other problems but
the
the results of our work feedback you
know uh into each other
that's great and while we're
i see a few people are very familiar
with aim lab versus sam mentioned that
well while we're waiting for some of the
questions to come in from the audience
something i'd love to ask you about from
a follow-up uh previous sex session was
around resume reviews
and i know we had brought that up about
yeah how it'd be great to be able to
connect people from the community
people that could share their resume and
others that could help provide feedback
and i'm curious
if there is specific feedback or tips
that you generally share with people
um
good question
i i think
um
so first of all i i think
i a theme that i've seen on this
uh the data science hangout but just in
general online
among the data science community is like
well how do i transition how do i get my
first job in data science and i i think
part of the
problem is
the
just the word data scientist it it
means so many different things that at a
certain point it loses meaning right if
uh i i think
people use that term to describe
um
you know a business analyst or
uh
someone you know in another context
someone could just use the same term to
describe
someone
who's using neural nets to solve
problems
um
right now i don't do either of those
things
you know so
i i think
partly
the data science community might need to
start doing a better job at
um
describing these different kinds of jobs
because if you're just starting out
or you're trying to whether you're
transitioning out of academia
or you're an undergrad or graduating
with a master's degree and you know you
want to be you want to go into data
science like what does that even mean so
i think
it might be
you know a good if the community could
come up with
some better definitions i know there are
some people who have done some really
good work around that
um
and
as far as like general advice i i would
say one of the things that i've seen
um
are people who are not this is what we
talked about previously people who are
not good at
um
at promoting themselves and i
uh
in a previous life was definitely guilty
of that
and so i think just this that skill
alone learning how to write about your
own accomplishments
um
as if it was someone else writing for
you
is is a skill to learn
on its own yeah
yeah i think that was something libby
had mentioned before
in the chat too like thinking about
somebody else writing that about you
it's good to come back
um i will mention too that
this is just an experiment but i was
thinking if we wanted to start like a
resume review club
through the data science hangout i did
make a google form where
you could just say like you could upload
your resume
or you could raise your hand to say
i would love to help review someone
else's
so i just put that link in the chat if
people want to check it out
yeah um i i would say this is totally my
fault i did this to myself
this came up because
uh
i don't know how long ago was maybe
three three four weeks ago um someone at
state space forwarded me a resume for
someone who was applying for um one of
our our data analyst positions
um and you know asking is this person
qualified you know should i tell them to
apply
um and so i i looked at the resume
and
you know immediately certain things
jumped out at me
like
the
the most important accomplishment like
within each job that previous you know
previous job that had been posted the
most important accomplishment at that
job was listed last
in the bullet points
[Music]
for
more than one job that was listed this
person was
before giving themselves credit for
anything was referring to their
colleagues
which is wonderful you know like i
trained under so you know this person
who helped me or i contributed to
something something something but then
they had done things on their own and
they weren't promoting that stuff first
um and then out of curiosity i looked at
this person's linkedin page and saw well
they were all there's a whole bunch of
amazing things that were listed on their
linkedin page that hadn't even made it
onto their resume
so
i i responded and said
you know they may very well be qualified
to apply for this job but before that
happens like forget about this job
this person just needs to
really redo their resume and and
um do a better job at telling everyone
how wonderful they are
um and then
after i saw that i um
i messaged uh
the the new york
uh slack chapter for the the new york um
our ladies uh slack group asking you
know does anyone know of like a forum
where people can
get their resume reviewed
and
you know there wasn't really a response
um
and then i mentioned it on a data
science hangout and realized like oh i
just assigned that to myself probably
so
but yeah right no
thank you rachel for
for kicking that off because i can't i
can't do it by myself i think that's
part of the point
um
yeah thank you for
the idea of it and
we we had a few people use it already
even just as an experiment and got great
feedback on how the process worked um
i'll i'm sure we'll have more people
starting to use it so i'll i'll keep in
touch with you of how that's how that's
going
um i see ethan you just put a question
into the chat if you want to just jump
in
yeah um hi jenny i'm in la fan fps
junkie
so
when i'm going to see that there's a
name that
company i'm so excited that you'll be
talking about
um so you mentioned that lab was started
by neuroscientists um i'm curious how
the task because i basically for
everyone here aim labs basically you
have different
tasks that you um send like basically
sensory tasks that you click on
um and how was the task first designed
was it driven by
the
um neurological science side on the
gaming side
and also
um could you give us a flavor of what
sorts of analysis you can do on aimlab
data
basically i'm trying to imagine
gamers actually help healthcare research
um yeah
so uh
they can um
so
the
the first
tasks um and and the underlying
technology
was
um developed
based on uh the kinds of experiments
that
often go on in in psych labs um except
with
um
a much more
boring stimulus
uh you know like there's a horizontal
line on the screen and there's a
vertical line on the screen and you know
click when you see this
so
some of those basic types of experiments
are
were basically overlaid with gaming
scenarios
um
so well not just exactly i see someone
in the chat not just executive function
tasks but um
there are i don't know maybe at least
like a hundred tasks right now in name
lab some of them concentrate more on you
know tracking something that's moving
like a smooth uh tracking movement some
of them are more
um ballistic movements some of them
assess working memory
um but
the trick with
something like in lab is that you know
like i said a typical experiment in a
lab
you know people are paid
they're there for you know maybe an hour
um
and it's boring
but they're being paid so if it's a game
it has to be fun right um
so the tasks
in aimlab have to balance
um
the
you know from the the perspective of the
scientists being able to collect
scientifically
useful data
um while
being fun enough that
that people want to play it and also
being similar enough to the gaming
scenarios that they're actually trying
to train for
so it's a it's a total balance it's a
continuous balance
um when you know for any of the tasks
that are
designed
um
you share an article in what the
washington post about like um people
actually asked you guys to can you make
the game more lucky just to make it more
similar to the actual game
like the tournament they have to compete
in i think the article mentioned like
pubg gamers that they asked you guys can
you lower the fps so that it
simulate the actual tournament that
they're in
yeah i mean people can you know change
their their settings in the game to you
know simulate
whatever they're using in their favorite
game
um but we have
um
[Music]
a couple of times we have asked
aimlab users to participate in
um
research projects
so we have had you know research
projects that were done
directly with you know small numbers of
of aim lab users but for the most part
people are just playing the game however
they want to play the game with whatever
equipment they want to use
typically in their home it could be two
in the morning it could be one in the
afternoon
you know somebody might play it for 10
minutes somebody might play it
every day
um
and you know that's just so so those are
not experiments exactly right it's just
whatever data is coming in
um we also like i said we now have this
digital health
um group so we
are using tasks
we're sort of taking the tasks from
aimlab and in some cases porting them to
a tablet in some cases leaving them
as a you know pc based
tasks
we were working with several different
universities on projects
uh having to do with assessing
concussion
assessing
uh cognitive changes under
um
hypoxia so
low levels of oxygen oxygen deprivation
that you might experience at high
altitude
we have another research project
with
pediatric cerebral palsy patients
um so the same technology
that's and and
um
gamify tasks that are that were built
for aimlab
um can be used for for these research
purposes and to
you know assess
cognitive and motor performance outside
of gaming
yeah i guess like
on the side of gamifications if it is
it's not just
making it like a game you also have the
review part so after every sessions on
mlap if you know um it will actually
tell you what you're good at and you're
tracking your performance over time
so it's telling you something that you
may have a lower left side screen
weaknesses so maybe you're slower on
that area so which is quite interesting
the other side is that you have a
leaderboard
so people can publish their results yeah
right so so people use it as a
you know to warm up before they play for
their favorite game or as a trainer
to improve in their favorite game but
like i mentioned before there are plenty
of people who
just you know enjoy playing in aimlab as
it is and compete
for positions on the leaderboard
yeah
thanks jenny
it's interesting to think about
all the data behind the games and i mean
i know wordle is one that's been
top of mind for a lot of people lately
but thinking like what data could be
behind that too
um i see there was an anonymous question
that came in that was what are some
things or skills specific to research
that aren't traditionally part of a data
science exclusive role
um
you mean what are some of the skills
that
are
specific to the
i i assume this person is asking what
are some of the skills that are specific
to like the r d team versus the data
science team
i think so yeah okay um so
for for one some of the
some of the roles on the r d team
really require
domain expertise
so
some of the people on the r d team have
phds in
neuroscience cognitive psychology
um
uh
bioengineering but specifically brain
you know people have worked on on brain
computer interface projects so
people who
have experience analyzing very specific
types of data
um and who have a background in in
cognitive
neuroscience cognitive psychology
which you know isn't necessary you know
isn't necessary for
um some of the other uh data science or
or analytics roles at the company
speaking of roles at the company i know
that you are hiring for a bunch of
different roles
right and curious to hear
what you're looking for in each of those
roles and
if they're on your team or
yeah so i am not a hiring manager for
for any of the current roles we don't
um have a role currently right now i'm
on the the r d team
um so the data and analytics team has i
believe two
openings right now
um yes aaliyah this is one of my
co-workers is is on the
uh
is on the call so there's
uh
uh
data scientist roles on the analytics
team
um and there's also a marketing
analytics position which i believe is
separate from the the data scientist
roles there's also
um in the
in digital health there's a
a
there's a role in the digital health
team that would be
more along the lines of a
biostatistician
so those are the
current
open
you know data related roles but i should
mention that there's plenty of of open
roles there's plenty of openings in
[Music]
engineering marketing
product
so
if you have you know friends who might
be interested definitely
direct them
to our i think all of the jobs are
listed on on lever but i'm sure if you
just google it people would find all of
the open positions
awesome and aaliyah feel free to share
them in the chat too if you want to
share the
links to the job postings
um but
just a reminder to everyone feel free to
just raise your hand on zoom if you want
to just jump in
live as well
but one question jenny i i'd love to ask
you
and we actually used to ask this at the
beginning of all the data science
hangouts but it's what are you most
excited about
um
right now
in data science for the next year
or projects that work that are most
exciting to you um so
for
me
at uh
the current projects that we're working
on i think
um you know state space is a is a young
company
um
so we're at the point now
uh where i
we are
better able to take advantage of all the
data that that we're collecting um
so
you know we have this enormous volume of
of performance data of human performance
data
um
we've been able to to write a couple of
of journal articles based on that
um so if you're if you're coming from
academia
the
the size of our data sets
um is really exciting
um so so that you know sort of like a
playground if you're if you're coming
out of academia to have access to such a
large amount of data
um so on a regular basis i find that
exciting
um
but we're at a point now
where
we are going to be able to
you know combine data from the different
products that we have so that they can
feed off of each other to really
maximize the experience of our users
and get better at
personalizing
the user's experience
to help them improve so i think that
um
you know it's been like a long time
coming
um
and
you know before you can do something
like that you actually have to just
spend a lot of time immersing yourself
in the data to even figure out what's
there
so yeah so that that's on the horizon
thank you
um i know
just from linkedin and i spend a lot of
time on linkedin but that you had
previously had your own consulting
company as well and
i know there's a lot of people in the
data science space who maybe even during
covet just recently started consulting
businesses
and i'd love to hear a bit about your
experience in that and
if you have some tips that you might
share with people listening
yeah so
i
um
my my initial academic training was in
anthropological genomics um i worked in
a psychiatric genetics lab
for a number of years
um
and then when i left academia the role
that i had was uh
in a
center for stem education at nyu's
engineering school
and i did
um some
uh
you know project outcome
measures
i instituted a lot of uh
a lot of quantification of the programs
that they were offering to
you know they they offered programs to
like thousands of local
kids in middle school in high school but
weren't necessarily keeping track of the
effects
that the programs had so i was able to
um to institute that write some papers
on that i wrote a lot of grants
in that role
and
a specific problem came up
that
i thought i can solve i i can probably
solve this with r and it had been a
couple of years since i had had to use r
i think i started using r in grad school
probably like 2004. so there was no r
studio it was all command line um
but i thought i i there's this problem
and i'm pretty sure i can you know find
a package and solve it in r
um and when i started doing that i was
like you know
i miss this i miss this part like i i
loved my job i loved the people i worked
with um
but i realized like i i need to i need
to do this again so i left that job and
set aside a chunk of time
to um turn myself into a data science
consultant
um and to do that i
and i i know this is advice given you
know maybe controversial advice given to
people like oh assign yourself projects
and make a blog and so which i did and i
i do understand that in order to be able
to do that you have to have
enough free time
um to
to be able to accomplish that which i
did
um
and you know basically assign myself
problems that would force me to have to
learn
new packages new tools new analytical
methods um
and after doing that i landed a a
gig as a
consultant for an education non-profit
that had a gigantic
longitudinal data set
and i worked for them for about maybe
like a year and a half
um
before starting
uh at state space and even for state
space i at first i was a consultant
writing a really large grant like a
monster grant
um
didn't get funded but that's okay
because it later laid groundwork for a
lot of other stuff
um
and then and then i was i was hired uh
full-time at state space
um
but
yeah so that
i was not
you know a full-time employee for this
company the i mean for the for the
non-profit the education nonprofit but
it took up enough of my time that it was
you know for me basically a full-time
job
what was that transition like of being a
consultant
for a company and then coming on
full-time
um
so state space is unusual it's uh
the culture is unusual
the
you know the flexibility of the work
hours is unusual so i it may like the
transition for me um
might not be what other people would
experience
um
[Music]
the company has been remote from the
beginning
there was no real office when
the company was really small
and
then people started
getting hired who were in different time
zones
there were thoughts of getting an office
but then the pandemic hit
so
and in the meantime the company raised
more money and expanded there are people
who work at first aid space
you know all over the world um
you know we manage
uh
you know in a single meeting there could
be people on like seven different time
zones right so
um
and the
the culture at state space is um
people just have to get their work done
so nobody's really a nine to five
employee at state space
um
and i i understand that
that that also
uh
some people have uh negative opinions
about a company that's run that way
where
you know the work hours are like just
get your work done it's whatever the
hours are that that you need to do it
and you know there's no specific
vacation time just take vacation when
you need it
um and i understand that
there are
circumstances in which a company might
take advantage of that or where people
might work for a company that has that
kind of policy where they would feel
um
really pressured to just never take
vacation
uh and then it's just that's just not
how it works at state space
so
i think i've had there's one job that i
had when i left academia um
i think i was there for maybe a year uh
not not the not the job at nyu was a
different job where it was really nine
to five and i remember the first time i
had to
i had a dentist appointment i had just a
dental cleaning and i had to take a half
of a of a sick day
to get
my teeth cleaned and i was just like i
don't i don't think i can deal with this
and and i i totally understand this is
just a personal preference there are
plenty of people who want a job where
they know
at you know 5 p.m or 6 p.m i'm done
nobody can bother me and when it's the
weekend it's my weekend and no one can
bother me
for me and
my family this the level of flexibility
that
i have at state space is actually really
important and
um you know a huge benefit for me so
as far as like the hours and you know
there wasn't
for me it didn't feel like such a big
transition going from consulting to
working full-time at state space
um
other than you know i just
uh
i i
now have like a lot more colleagues and
um you know work definitely work more
hours
yeah
it sounds like there is an awesome
culture at state space just from even
previous conversations that we had as
well and i see sam you actually just
asked a question about this as well do
you want to jump in
or i can i can read it and you can add
context but it's how do you ensure
employees at state space have a
work-life balance to avoid burnout
um that's a good question um
i mean it is definitely a risk so
managers have to be
really careful and be on top of that
to make sure that that doesn't happen
i think it depends on the role that
somebody has at the company and the
level of of responsibility that they
have
for
some of the people in for example
engineering or we have a really really
large community team
meaning that people who
are
on discord or twitter communicating you
know in constant communication with
users responding in real time
when people have a question
or have a problem
um and so for those people
you know certainly there's work to do on
the weekends or
if something crashes
there have to be engineers who are
willing to to fix something
um on the weekends but uh yeah managers
just have to be really careful about
um who has to take responsibility for
that kind of thing like in an emergency
yeah yeah
thank you and thanks sam for asking that
question as well because i think that's
something that
a lot of us
i mean i know there's a lot of talk
around burnout
but how do people know when they're
actually
experiencing burnout before it's too
late
yeah and again i think that that is
uh
an issue that people have with companies
that have this sort of
you know nebulous
working hours and lack of specific
vacation time
um
[Music]
all i can say is i think it's working
pretty well at state space um you know
personally i haven't had a problem with
it
you know up to now i mean i
i appreciate um
being able to you know in the middle of
the week if if i have to take two hours
in the in during business hours to make
phone calls to manage my 87 year old
mother's health care
i can do that
i can if it's you know a family member's
birthday i can stop working at three and
make a cake from scratch and do whatever
i want to do to help them celebrate
their birthday and then i don't feel
um
for me personally
then i
get work done on the weekend because
it's really quiet and i don't have any
meetings i don't have any work related
meetings
uh
and it doesn't
it doesn't bother me that i'm doing that
because i also know that
you know i have the freedom in the
middle of the week to
to exercise or do you know do these
other things that i need to do
but but it's definitely a personal
preference there are people who
really need
um specific work hours for their
lifestyle
i'm curious from the the group here as
well like if you have other tips too for
avoiding burnout or if there's things
people want to share in the chat
you see zach you put a
a question in the chat if you wanted to
jump in yeah i was just uh of course
like uh
i'm british uk laws a lot different to
us law especially around holiday
uh and to take time off i was wondering
how do you make sure again it's the
burnout question and then uh
is there a minimum days off if even
because you said there's not like
unlimited you can take as much face off
how would you ensure
other than just a general culture thing
that actually
people do take enough days off because
otherwise they will burn out no matter
how much they love their work
so
hr does uh keep tabs on that and they
will
make people take time off like i mean
they can see who's
not taking time off
um so yeah occasionally people are
just told like go disappear for a while
i think you need to do that
yeah
i i know we had to do that at our studio
because we did have or we do have
unlimited time off but sometimes when
you have unlimited you don't actually
take it off
so we have like quarterly check-ins now
where you have to say like are you on
track to take this
amount
yeah that's really yeah that's really
good
i guess it's also the pandemic you're
not going on holiday or people are
starting now i know for me i've not
taken enough days off uh and oh right
from mine they reset end of march so
they just reset i always have to i i've
only worked a couple years where i
always get told of march i have to take
like four five six days off to make sure
i hit minimum requirements
yeah people don't even know what day of
the week it is anymore so that
definitely
made it made it more difficult
yeah
i like mark's tips in the chat too you
said a good manager who recognizes when
the team needs a break is key
yeah or or a manager who takes time off
themselves to set an example
definitely yeah
yeah i i've also been trying like on the
well this is new but on the weekend like
when 5 p.m friday hits to delete slack
off my phone
log out of my email
delete linkedin that's a big one for me
really i'm deleting linkedin and then
monday i'll let myself put it back on my
phone
so we'll see how that works
yeah i mean i i think for some people uh
like any other phone app these um
work-related phone apps
um people are just sort of addicted to
clicking on them
so yeah definitely i see there was a
another anonymous question earlier that
was any insight on how trends like 5g
and ar vr would shape the technology
investment with aim labs
um
so
i mean vr you know i think any company
that's working on
um anything related to video games you
know has to be paying attention to vr
uh
we have released a couple of aimlab
tasks
um on vr
so
you know i any any company that is
is working um
on anything that's presented in the form
of a video game whether it's for
entertainment or for healthcare
has to be
um
looking at at multiple
multiple platforms
pc console
mobile tablet vr
yeah
how have you seen
the
like customer experience or from the
data
based on if people are using vr
or not
well so we like i said we we've only
released a couple of tasks in the nvr
mode um
you know sort of as a test to um
just to test out that technology
they seem to be pretty well received i
mean there's you know i think the
the headset technology
still has a ways to go in terms of
um not everyone is physically
comfortable with headsets uh
you know there are people who get
nauseous from them
uh things like that
uh and there's also it's an additional
cost right like if you're trying to
reach a large number of people um
you know mobile phones are probably the
easiest way to reach the largest number
of people without
uh assuming that everybody's gonna go
out and buy another piece of equipment
so right now headsets are are
pretty expensive and it's not like most
people have it in their home
when you were talking about some of the
work that
state space is doing in public health
do you have partnerships with
like different hospitals or
organizations or
what does that look like
so
right now we have several
research projects that are that are
ongoing
one with mount sinai hospital in new
york
that's the project that we're doing
where
pediatric patients with cerebral palsy
are using some
aim lab tasks that have been adapted
for
you know some are on tablet some are on
pc but adapted for use in that context
and for that
it's not only um
that the mechanics of the tasks had to
be changed but all of the
imagery and sounds and text had to be
changed because there can't be any gun
imagery or you know anything about
shooting like that this is a tool that's
being used in a hospital and with kids
so uh the design team had to totally
overhaul
the tasks and you know turn like remove
anything having to do with a gun or
words having to do with kill or shooting
um one of the tasks it's a tracking task
and and this is just like one of my
favorite things that
um
that came out of of our work over the
the past year it's a it's a tracking
task so you know someone has to follow
something that's moving on the screen
and track it
uh and so instead of
instead of targets like round shaped
targets um
the targets are are
cats
and
um
they
i don't know if for people who are
familiar with video games
the a target's health or an opponent's
health
is uh you know sometimes shown on the
screen as like a decrease a bar that's
decreasing in size or like you know some
something that's colored that's that's
fading so the
the cat's health is like a rainbow
that's basically coming out of the cat's
butt and it it just like shortens as the
cat's life
uh shortens so i yeah so we we had to
adapt the tasks for um freeze
for uh for pediatric patients and and
um definitely our design team had a lot
of fun with that one uh and then we have
partnerships at indiana university
where we have a large study uh going on
with a lot of the athletes at indiana
university
assessing
concussion
um using it using adapted in-lab tasks
and that's also at indiana university is
where we're doing a study on
hypoxia
yeah
and we've also partnered with
um
with companies that wanted to use aimlab
tasks to assess
their
products or to you know to test out
their products
um
so
we've done
some efficacy testing
uh where we
we've used aimlab task metrics as
outcome metrics
uh for efficacy
efficacy testing of nutritional
supplements in partnership
um
with a
a cro
and
we've uh
built tasks for
for kernel which is a neuroscience-based
company
um
so
yeah we we're using lab tasks for other
other kinds of research
cool thank you
i see raphael you just put something a
question into the chat would you want to
ask that one live
yeah i think
yeah i see this question about um
uh you've read an article saying that
cognitive abilities begin to decline at
26
and uh
we rely on previous experience more at
that age so is this true and doesn't
mean i have to try harder to beat my 12
year old
brother
so that's a good question
we did collect some data on age and
performance in aimlab
and
our data did indicate that
performance seems to peak
um
before 26 like 24 25 years old but that
i i would qualify that by saying that um
you know our the data that we're
collecting our data set is messy this is
not under controlled conditions right
our users are
playing aimlab at home all of their
equipment is different um
we have no idea what time of day they're
playing right we don't collect
information on their gender so it's not
like this was done in a lab but our
our data
showed that there was a decline after
like mid-20s and and there have been
published studies on
uh
that are
that were conducted under with data
conducted under controlled conditions
that that
have
some similar results like at around that
age
yeah but but yeah you know
things like
game sense and experience um
uh
you know cognitive control in terms of
restraining yourself so you don't
shoot
a teammate instead of an enemy things
like that
you know age might give you an advantage
jenny i see raphael saying oh no
i was thinking the same
jordan i see you have your hand raised
if you want to jump in
uh yeah sure so specifically on that
last question so i
work at a company that also does
cognitive testing more focused with
health care and clinical trials
um so our goal wasn't always to make
them kind of fun uh
but funny enough we partnered with a lot
of seems like we partnered with some of
the same people um but specifically on
the like uh
declining like cognitive abilities kind
of posts like 20s mid-20s
we
um yeah i mean generally depending on
the task you do see a route you do see
some like declines from that it's the
pinnacle
but just so that in case anyone's
worried
they're probably not gonna be noticeable
um you might be psyching yourself out a
bit too much with it um
that we have um cognitive test
performance data from
um like eight years to like 90
and for a lot of these tasks there's not
a big uh difference
things that involve reaction time you
will see a decline
but things that rely on sort of accuracy
or um some sorts of met or depending on
the memory paradigm you won't have um
you won't you won't have like a
significant decrease um unless there is
some neurodegenerative disorder or some
sort of injury but if you're generally
healthy person um
you can probably still beat your 12 year
old brother
yeah i mean the other the other thing
that's important is sleep
uh so um
yeah you need to you you know i think i
think there are people who who think
that if they practice you know just like
cramming for a test well if i practice
for hours and hours i'll get better but
if you do that
until it's like three in the morning
then you're actually you know
not
you you won't retain what you're
learning right if you're practicing and
training you're not going to really
retain it
um and also
you know lack of sleep in general
um harms cognitive performance and and
gaming is a cognitive task so
yeah you should get everyone should get
some sleep
sleep sleep deprivation is actually how
some cognitive tests um
uh validate themselves because yeah
everyone knows that not enough sleep is
bad for you so sometimes
um for some cognitive tests like we you
can replicate or you can demonstrate
that it is sort of measuring
um aptitude because you can see that in
the group that had sleep deprivation
they didn't perform well um it's more
ethical than
giving people brain injuries so yeah
yeah
but you do yeah don't
definitely get sleep sleep is very good
yeah yeah
yeah i mean that's it's similar to the
uh the oxygen deprivation um study that
we're doing where you know oxygen upper
deprivation sounds um
it sounds worse than it is this is like
simulating high altitude
uh levels of
of low oxygen
so it's you know something easily
reversible like you know quickly
reversible and it's not you know harming
anyone
but it it can't it it should
uh result in in some cognitive changes
thank you i see through a few anonymous
questions that came into
but sam i saw you just put into the chat
what is state space's view on the recent
controversy around
roblox is that how i pronounce it for
child exploitation
oh i i would not i
would leave that up to our lawyers or
our ceo to answer first of all i'm not
really sure what that refers to exactly
but yeah
that is a video yeah definitely not a
question he put a uh
there was a a link in the chat but
we can uh i can share that later too the
anonymous question was some companies
showcase their products and services on
virtual showrooms almost like a first
person video game experience
do you see value in that
um
i'm i
would need slightly more of an
explanation to answer that question i'm
not really sure
yeah some of those questions are
anonymous too so
feel free to just like add context on
slido too if you want
or to the person that asked it yeah
but i'll go i'll go to the other
anonymous question that was there too
and this was
are these the tasks that you're talking
about are these proprietary proprietary
tests or tasks that are developed for
devices or are they traditional
cognitive tests that are redeveloped
oh
um
so
some of our
our analytics are proprietary
um
and
some of the tasks that we've developed
are definitely unique and proprietary
uh
but
you know and then some of them are
like i said based on
uh
experiments that are done in psych labs
you know around the world but
the
uh
they're made more fun in in in lab yeah
so the you know the imagery and the
sounds are
make them make them more fun but
i i think
the tasks that are in aimlab that
you know you could say are
taken directly from
um from
academic research
that proportion is probably pretty small
and most of the tasks are
more
simulating scenarios that people would
encounter in a game
but with
the the
measurements underlying it
are proprietary
thank you
can i um
ask you if there are any resources or
podcasts or books that you've liked
recently
that you've you'd recommend to us oh my
gosh um
i
related to data science
um it doesn't have to be it could be
give you more general i don't know i
think actually i have a a a problem with
that in that like i feel
like um
i bookmark so many things you know i
think whether it's twitter or linkedin
you come across things that look like oh
this will be really useful to read
or um
you know useful video to watch and
there's almost like too many of them
uh so i know i personally have a have a
problem with that
yeah but um
[Music]
uh so i ca i can't
give something specific right now i mean
i yeah
i i mean i definitely rely heavily on
the
you know the our community
whether it's blog posts or
um
you know all of the material that's free
that other people who use r create it's
you know one of the reasons that that i
stick with r
that's awesome i i see that ian moore is
on from epsilon and ian i
wanted to give you a moment to share
about the shiny conference if you wanted
to jump in
hey rachel sorry i didn't expect this at
all oh sorry i just really just put you
on the spot but i saw you oh
yet it's happening at the end of the
month and we have an incredible lineup
we're super excited about it this is
going to be the first epsilon shiny
conference so there's you know some
things we're working out but
the general time zone i believe is uh
from 5 a.m to uh i think 1 p.m eastern
time but um most of the main content is
going to be happening later in the day
awesome thanks ian yeah i just put the
the link in the chat too
yeah thanks again it should be great
well thank you so much jenny for joining
us today and for sharing all your
insights and about state space it's
great to great to chat with you and i
appreciate you mentioning the
the need to have this platform to help
each other review resumes too so
hopefully we can yeah
yeah i'm really
uh excited to see what happens with that
so thank you i can see a few people
already filled out the form just from
the call oh really okay awesome okay
great
um and then and i know aaliyah posted
links to
um i don't know if that was a link to
like all of our job listings or
the specifically the analytics job
listings but um
but i can also
uh i can share a link
um
perfect yeah other job listings and i
can put that with the recording as well
and as well as in the linkedin data
science community group
um i'll put those job postings there too
but thank you all so much